BACK TO THAT ISSUE.
TAMMY, THANK YOU, DANA, AS
ALWAYS, THANK YOU AS WELL.
NOW WE TURN TO OTHER DISTURBING
NEWS SURROUNDING JOE BIDEN.
HE HAS UNTIL THE SINGLE PRESS
CONFERENCE, HAS NO PLANS TO GIVE
A STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
HIS VICE PRESIDENT HAS
APPARENTLY TAKEN OVER THE DUTIES
OF TALKING ONE-ON-ONE AND HAVING
THESE MEETINGS WITH WORLD
LEADERS AND LAST WEEK, DURING A
RARE PUBLIC APPEARANCE, BIDEN
STRUGGLED, AND I MEAN STRUGGLED,
MIGHTILY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I PROMISE YOU WE ARE GOING
TOGETHER BEAT THIS AND I THINK
THAT -- YOU KNOW, BUT THE IDEA
THAT OVER 500 -- I THINK IT’S --
I HAVE A CARD, I CARRY A CARD
WITH ME EVERY DAY, THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY THE -- AS OF
YESTERDAY, THERE ARE 500,071
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED FROM THIS.
>> Sean: WHAT ELSE IS ON THE
CARD?
THAT WAS NOT A HARD NUMBER TO
REMEMBER BECAUSE THEY HAD A
VIGIL THE DAY BEFORE.
MY NAME IS JOE, MY WIFE ’HIS
NAME IS JILL, I LIVE AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE.
THIS IS GETTING SCARY.
OVER THE WEEKEND IT GOT WORSE.
DURING SOME RAMBLING REMARKS HE
COMPLETELY FORGOT WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT AND, WELL, I THINK
CONGRESSMAN SHEILA JACKSON LEE
IS PRETTY WELL-KNOWN AND HER
NAME IS NOT SHIRLEY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WANT TO THANK YOU,
GOVERNOR , MRS. ABBOTT, FOR YOUR
HOSPITALITY AND YOUR FRIENDSHIP
AND REPRESENTATIVE --
SENATOR CORNYN, I THINK HE HAD
TO GO BACK, I THINK IS GETTING
ON A PLANE, HE TOLD ME HE CAME
IN TO SEE ME LAST EVENT AND
REPRESENTATIVE
SHEILA JACKSON LEE, AL GREEN,
SYLVIA GARCIA -- EXCUSE ME AND
WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
I’M GOING TO LOSE TRACK HERE.
>> Sean: WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
HER NAME IS SHEILA JACKSON LEE,
CONGRESSWOMAN
SHEILA JACKSON LEE.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT IN THE
HILL, THERE ARE NO WHISPERS AT
BIDEN’S CHIEF OF STAFF RON KLAIN
IS ACTUALLY RUNNING THE SHOW
WHILE JOE NAPS.
A MEMBER HE LOOKS SO EXHAUSTED.
OH.
I CARRY A PAPER WITH ME TO
REMIND ME EVERY DAY.
JUST GO BACK FOUR YEARS AGO AND
LOOK AT TAPES OF JOE.
GO BACK TEN YEARS AGO, WHICH
BRINGS US TO A VERY SERIOUS BUT
REAL NECESSARY QUESTION.
OF HIS JOE BIDEN -- IS THIS FAR
WORSE THAN WE WERE EVER TOLD?
’S SEE FIT TO SERVE?
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE SAME
QUESTIONS THE DEMOCRATS, THE
MEDIA, THEY HAD NO PROBLEM
ASKING ABOUT RONALD REAGAN, THE
AGE QUESTION, THEY CALLED IT IN
THE LATE ’80s OR ABOUT
JOHN McCAIN DURING HIS
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS, THEY
ALL TALKED ABOUT IT OPENLY.
GIVEN WHAT WE NOW SEE FROM
JOE BIDEN DAY AFTER DAY AFTER
DAY, THIS IS NOW A FAIR QUESTION
THAT NEEDS TO BE ASKED.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE AIDE TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, ALSO
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S LEADING
SPEECHWRITER, STEVE MILLER IS
WITH US.
ALL RIGHT, LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
JOE QUESTION AND THEN WE WILL
QUICKLY GO TO THE TRANSITION OF
THE SPEECH.
THIS IS -- LOOK, WE USED TO GET
CRITICIZED WHEN I SAID WEAK,
FRAIL, AND STRUGGLING
COGNITIVELY.
I’M KNOCKING AND CRITICIZED ANY
LONGER.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT IS,
STEPHEN?
BECAUSE EVERYBODY SEES IT.
>> THIS WOULD BE COMICAL, SEAN,
IF IT WEREN’T SO TRULY
TERRIFYING.
THE QUESTION IS, WHO IS ACTUALLY
MAKING THE DECISIONS RUNNING
THIS COUNTRY NOW?
WHO MADE THE DECISION TO START A
BORDER CRISIS IN THE FIRST MONTH
OF THIS PRESIDENCY?
WHO MADE THE DECISION TO REJOIN
THE PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD, STOP
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE?
SHUTDOWN ENERGY PRODUCTION
NATIONWIDE?
WHO MADE THE DECISION TO START
FUNDING ABORTION OVERSEAS WITH
YOUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS?
CLEARLY SOMEBODY IS MAKING ALL
THESE DECISIONS AND IT’S NOT
JOE BIDEN AND IT’S AFFECTING
REAL LIVES AND REAL PEOPLE AND
WE ARE ENTITLED TO ANSWERS.
>> Sean: YEAH, I TOTALLY
AGREE.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME MOVE ON.
SO WHAT I LIKED A LOT AT CPAC,
97% SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT’S
POLICIES.
THAT KIND OF TELLS YOU THE
DIRECTION OF THE PARTY.
I THINK THOSE IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT WING THAT THINK
THAT THAT -- THAT THE PARTY IS
GOING TO GO BACKWARDS AWAY FROM
THE TRUMP AMERICA FIRST, MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AGENDA ARE
WRONG.
THE AGENDA IS WHAT IT IS AND
IT’S FAIRLY SIMPLE.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT SPELLED ALL
OF THAT OUT AND HE ALSO ADDED TO
IT THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
FIX WITH ELECTIONS SO PEOPLE
HAVE CONFIDENCE AND INTEGRITY IN
OUR ELECTION PROCESS.
IT IS VERY CLEAR ON THAT AS WELL
WELL.
>> HE GAVE A POWERHOUSE SPEECH,
SEAN, THAT RALLY REPUBLICANS AND
RALLIED CONSERVATIVES AROUND THE
VALUES THAT ARE GOING TO WIN
BACK THE MIDTERMS AND WIN THE
WHITE HOUSE IN FOUR YEARS AND HE
WAS ESPECIALLY EFFECTIVE AND
LACERATING IN CONDEMNING
JOE BIDEN’S COWARDICE ON SCHOOL
REOPENING’S.
CHILDREN ARE HURTING ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND I APPLAUD
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST AS A
CITIZEN FOR SAYING WHAT NEEDED
TO BE SAID, GET THE SCHOOLS
OPEN, GET OUR KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL!
IS JOE BIDEN SO TERRIFIED OF THE
TEACHERS UNION THAT HE’S GOING
TO SACRIFICE LITERALLY THE
FUTURES OF MILLIONS OF YOUNG
KIDS ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY?
IT NEEDED TO BE SAID AND
DONALD TRUMP SAID IT AND HE SAID
A LOT MORE, ABOUT OUR ECONOMY,
ABOUT ENERGY, ABOUT RECOVERY,
ABOUT COVID, AND HE WAS
ESPECIALLY EFFECTIVE, IN MY VIEW
VIEW, IN HIM -- IN HIS DETAILED
TAKEDOWN OF JOE BIDEN’S BORDER
POLICIES AND WHAT HE’S DONE
ALONG THE SOUTHWEST BORDER WHERE
WE HAD A SECURE BORDER AND NOW
WE HAVE AN UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS.
WHAT YOU SAW WITH THAT SPEECH
WAS WHAT EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE
DOING NATIONWIDE.
INEFFECTUAL, DETAILED ISSUE BY
ISSUE REBUTTAL OF THE FIRST
MONTH OF THE MOST FAR LEFT